et bien bonjour à chaque fois
j'opterais pour
ok
[Applaudissements]
je détiens vite et n'avait pas mis tout
à côté de moi a reconnu mais pas toi ça
ça va encore matthieu sauvé les amis
nous sommes ici réunis pour débriefer ce
qui a été le plus gros buzz on va
appeler ça de l'histoire de ma chaîne
youtube
peut-être c'était un peu bizarre de
faire une vidéo pour débriefer une autre
vidéo sauf qu'en fait il ya eu tellement
de trucs inattendue dans cette aventure
des hits de l'été de surprise de tous
qu'on soit ré et surtout ça a marché
cent fois plus que ce qu'on avait
imaginé nous au moment où on a mis la
ville et vaucluse mais il voit plus du
coup il ya plein d'anecdotes à raconter
plein d'image que vous avez jamais vu
qu'on va aussi pouvoir vous montrer
notamment le moment où je tombe sur
scène ouais quoi tu es tombé sur scène
un an sur les pelles à huawei cette
image est folle tout a commencé
moi j'ai utilisé 10 de l'été qu'il
faisait marrer ça fait un moment que je
kiffe la musique se faisait aussi jordan
et on n'avait jamais fait tout ensemble
merci beaucoup et l'anecdote c'est que
je ne connaissais lee kesa unis freddy
c'est bon à la base d'ailleurs les gars
vous deviez vous devriez même pas être
là en fait on était en plaçant sur le on
va pas tu es remplaçant mais bon à la
base j'avais contacté masqué et alison
muller parce que je voulais qu'il y ait
un duo avec une voix féminine
je trouvais ça cool sauf que comme le
tournage demandé trois jours non-stop
limaces kenya ellison ne pouvait pas ce
qu'ils avaient des projets un emploi du
temps finalement parce que je respecte
totalement est donc plutôt qu'au chômage
[Musique]
masqué me recommande khezzar en me
disant lui zinc assure c'est bien ce
qu'il fait ça devrait plaire à la
remarquable kesaj moi qui me tape les
fais des trucs avec mister v rbx seb et
du coup j'appelle sais mais j'ai passé
l'été passé c'est vrai que sur l'île de
0 à 17 ans amara qu'elle à quel point de
ça 11 12
car si tu me dis [ __ ] mais qui je vais
inviter d'autres mecs tu peux être bon
en musique et tout s'est en fait toi tu
venais de sortir sur la chaîne golden
mustaq une parodie de jul qui est
excellente et donc je me dit vas-y il a
l'air de gérants musique et tout donc ça
peut être intéressant de 2,7 de manière
fort mal comme ça dans mes pensées je
t'ai formelle et ses marrons les cheveux
ça marrant ce truc de vous avez fait en
tout cas c'est un team qui est tourné
une vidéo ensemble sur une musique en
plus alors vous coûte et je trouve ça
tout ça rigole oui je connaissais freddy
par rapport à une vie que je me suis dit
si c'est les mêmes délires québec on va
trop bien s'entendre
j'étais moins stressé je me suis dit la
même chose pour que les gens comprennent
débriefer cas quel point ça a été un
succès fou bien plus mal qu'on ne le
pensait on va vous donner quelques
chiffres et quelques tu as tu déjà la
vidéo principe à la dure une heure 08 37
jours de montage je suis vous avez
masterclass parce que les rushs qu'on
lui ai envoyé mon gars c'est ça n'avait
aucun sens qu'ils avaient tous des
bordels ont été détruits dans désordre
il a dû tout mettre dans leurs fins même
un bordel
donc je pense qu on appelait on appelait
la vidéo dure 1h08 elle sort est
incroyable elle fait premières tendances
une vidéo d'une heure 08 premières
tendances pendant deux jours déjà ça
change très vite les tendances en le
risque qu'on a tendance souvent cette
heure après ça n'est plus et en plus
tard armand des vidéos de qui dure plus
de 25 minutes en attendant ce que ça va
bien peu sur la piste du [ __ ] les gens
ayant l'air de vraiment aimé on fait
tout ça et on annonce l'heure et le jour
de la sortie des clips cela n est pas un
club tient à vis d'eux et on l'annonçait
en toute fin de vidéo je me disais il ya
plein de gens qui ont fait au courant
bla bla bref faut savoir aussi que le
jour de la sortie du doc comme tu disais
en fait j'avais déjà un engouement sur
twitter moi je savais déjà comment fait
il enfin je voyais les gens déjà qui
commençait à dire moi je suis plus
stable
oui donc et des teams en fait les gens
en fait en fait beaucoup plus que ce
sera bon mais que les deux s'accordent
pas complètement raison les gens ce sont
vous êtes très entrer dans le truc du
mois je suis maintenant au mirador et
mieux les gars soyez objectif soit parce
qu'à ce prix dans bye bye que c'est
mieux
là il ya eu des victimes alors que nous
soyons honnêtes ce qu on s'en bat les
couilles
on s'en bat les couilles de qui gagnait
en fait c'était tellement ouf
ce qu'on a vécu on voulait qu'on a fait
les sons et tous qu'on n'était pas du
tout dans la compet on était juste en
mode les gains réels c'est un truc fou
génial
espérons qu'ils aient au moins l'un des
deux qui marchent tous les deux du
possible et voilà tu vois on était loin
d'imaginer ce qui allait suivre donc
déjà premier fail laissons sorte sur les
plateformes de streaming
une semaine après ce que regrettent les
sons sorte de jeudi soir bon on a un peu
dingue parce qu'on se dit amer des
assauts engouement et laissons le sont
pas dispo ailleurs que sur youtube un
peu le seul apple somme pourquoi un peu
le sommes parce que dans les classements
ce n'est pas les vues de vidéos youtube
ne compte pas mon gros ton clip il veut
faire 400 millions de vues sur youtube
va dire ça tu seras pas platine nos
diamants ou je sais pas quoi tu veux on
s'est tellement donné sur l'île sont
aussi qu'on avait envie vraiment cela de
mémoire sur les places en string parce
que ils avaient vraiment leur place trop
sur mason était que les gens demandent
énormément la première trace de cet
engouement extrêmes le fait
qu'effectivement les gens du coup
beaucoup de vidéos prises en boîte en
soirée il y avait même des gars genre
qu'est sud mais chez eux et il entendait
le son
chez les voisins du dessus ouais il y
avait des mecs des voitures qui
passaient avec le son à fond il ya des
gars qu'il met pas les gens ils ont
suivi des eaux en fait faut comprendre
que pour nous c'était pas gagné parce
que tu en as tu peur fait de la musique
il ya quand même un a priori totalement
justifiée vu jeudi de vouloir en fait y
compris moi dans leur histoire avec la
musique la personne avait sakory tout le
monde a adhéré aux trucs et du coup les
gens ne l'ont senti et ça leur a donné
envie de donner deux doses et partager
ne pas avoir honte d'écouter une musique
faite par des youtuber moncomble va pas
se mentir
ici personne écoute de musique j'adore
le jeu des accords en cours et non des a
priori que mes interventions a priori
que kim ça avait également quand il
était écouté très vrai il s'attendait à
un truc explosé guina et paradoxalement
à la fin et en deux temps mais il était
mais au moins je ne savais même pas vous
poser dans les tours est finalement s'en
suit une radio en france qui a joué le
jeu bien sûr et ouais souvenez vous en
faites vous en ce groupe
vous pourrez imaginer rappelle dès qu'on
disait imaginé ça se faisait pas ça ça
wily afin de radio alors qu'on n'est pas
passée chez eux ou quoi que ce soit il
joue je l'aimais conquis fait le débat
et ce jusqu'à aujourd'hui encore ouais
c'est vrai moi c'est là encore une à
deux fois jour il le passe coque la ruhr
jusqu'en 2025 2006 and radio vous l'a
jamais dit ça on a fait des petites
story pour la gym mais merci c'était ça
le rec trop plaisir c'est la première
fois que en tout cas il se passe un truc
sur la chaîne youtube et qui s était
repris par autant de gens d'autant de
milieux différents et qui contribue un
peu au délire à leur manière tu vois le
monte en cas d' excuses et qu il le
glisse dans un cat exclusive il ya eu un
but you buzz à clémentine m qui avait
fait une vidéo chorégraphie il ya un mec
qui a fait 20 voix sur mirador enfin oui
il ya plein d'hommes ont repris ça et
qu'on continuer sur cette lancée dès de
l'été et c'était pour moi une grande
première ce hacker autant de gens qui
réagissent et qui crée des choses autour
d'un contenu création engine youtube il
ya comme un historien nous envoyer les
as we première rencontre a qu'une
personne qui t'a reconnu pour mirador
merad en ressort une semaine après il ya
une fête de la musique dans ma ville ok
j'y vais donc c'est dans un petit parc
communal comme à l'accoutumée près
souvent dix minutes après je suis en
train d'être là à écouter la musique de
la fête et l'a400m qu'aux routes bas
tout le parc
autour de moi comme ça histoire qu'a
fait un truc avec squeeze leurs têtes
étaient hors champ russie de la caméra
quand ils ont à c toi
imaginez je suis personne moi ça m'est
arrivé de trois fois avant mais très
léger en fait normalement c'est très
progressif ça mais toi avec le truc de
l'été qui est du coup le calme le marché
une histoire mashaie 91 rue était dedans
this way s'est vraiment mal et ça c'est
vraiment toi maman les gens te
reconnaissent maintien demain n'ont pas
sorti mois de sortie de crise
je passe par des souterrains là à jordan
toit très peu intéressants mon côté à la
tête de moi je pouvais pas dire le
premier je pourrais dire un petit peu
comment cette fois ci en général disait
que singapour est atteint au moins il
nous l'a dit avant mais sinon on voit
que de l'amour à jennings qui était
drôle avec le contact avec les gens
c'est que dans la rue ils sont obligés
de dire je suis moi je faisais pas
franchement si ça en fait oui mais les
gens sont tellement mignons c'est que il
se disait ah non ça c'est pas ce que je
fais je préfère mirador mais note que ça
se fait pas le pauvre c je disais
tranquille pour sa légitime bas je n'ai
jamais fait un projet après qu'elle les
gens sont si bienveillant l'horizon rien
négatif à dire alors que je vous
rappelle qu'on fait quand même des clips
on se prend pour des ouf on fait les
mecs de malades dont un mode et c'est
hyper critique genre mais qui ne connaît
pas les duos de droit qu à dieu bon on
en est au chronologiquement alors un
grand événement je me dis franchement ce
serait trop bien pour faire kiffer les
gens qu'on le fasse sur sept mois je me
dis donc en ce moment et donc qu'est ce
qui se passe à ce moment là il ya tout
simplement les sauts leigh day d'un
festival incroyable monstrueux en plus
pour une magnifique cause puisqu'ils
luttent contre un festival c'est une
organe de malade mental met en place des
mois et des mois et on arrive on dit ce
qui n'en faisait pas d'une minute pour 4
personnes qui ne sont nobody totalement
de body et ils font banon est en fait de
fil en aiguille il ya plein de gens
qu'on continue ils se reconnaîtront si
elle a cette vidéo contribué au fait que
ça arrive aux oreilles du boss des
solidays bisous luc et luc accepte et
trouvent un moyen en fait au delà
d'accepter il trouve surtout un moyen de
vous placer à l'endroit créneau
entre deux trucs mais qu'on soit un
confort etc c'est juste avant la couleur
ce parti la corse partie au sud est
c'est là où tout le monde en voilà vous
savez déjà tout dans ces moments il ya
plus de gens dans la scène tout
simplement c'est le cas et nous on
chante juste avant ce moment terre on
chante et après on lance la colours
donc c'est le moment où devant nous il
ya cinquante mille personnes je crois et
nous n'avons aucune expérience de scène
du tout et avec j'aurai je me souviens
on a répété trois quatre cinq six fois
on a chanté ici un mode peut-être là tu
peux faire ça et moi je fais ça et que
ça
ce qui travaillent parce que sur scène
on a toi oui oui ça l'est plus du tout
c'est une langue comme mère maternelle
avait briefé je vous propose c'est quoi
qu'on regarde le rush de notre passage
sur la scène des solidays
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez que
je vous salut c moi bien je les regarde
et il n'y avait rien ne va rien ne va
c'est comme si vous toi qui regarde
cette vidéo tu montais sur une scène
devant 150 personnes qui n'a jamais fait
ça les gars cinquante mille alors petit
jeu doit spécifier un truc c'est que le
sont absolument horrible parce qu'en
fait ils audio qui est dupliquée fin
c'est l'enfer pendant ce temps on te
pardonne squeeze alors ça c'est un bout
de décor de angèle je vois exactement
parce que quand on passait en fait
c'était en train de set up le décor
mangel c'est pour ça qu'on a une scène
qui fait de mettre deux oies mais
qu'attendent les corps jusqu'au fond sa
cellule est un tout petit peu non
oui j'ai regardé bien l'admettre de moi
qui arrivais les gars je stresse alors
qu'il arrivait on sait que je suis pas
messieurs rappelez-vous juste dans le
déroulé qu'on avait fait je viens au
début seul devant 50000 personnes juste
pour mettre une clé usb dans une platine
je vous refais une reconstitution en
live de une seconde
j'aurais jamais assumé alors là ils
entendent se demandait il est où là
quelle valeur parce que moi là bas tu
vas pas sur scène parce que j'avais pas
micro j'ai pas de micro donc je suis
derrière le rideau en train de reculer
une dame qui merci ce qu'on a cherché
salling deux jours avant et sincères
excuses
elle a battu gala tu viens là single
regardez bien le fail qui arrivent et
j'arrive sur scène le micro ne marche
pas iger dans l'oeuf une liste de choses
horribles qui peuvent arriver qui en
première le micro est campé jeudi aux
gens vous allez leur personne regarde
est ce que ton micro a été activée
uniquement à partir du moment où tu dis
y'a pas de ce genre d'action ça arrive
tout de suite regardé pléthore yamaha
sont donc là je t'explique mois ce qui
se passe pendant ces moments de
flottement et jordan et moi en coulisses
ont fait des zones à migros qui font ou
les abonnés ont fait ils nous ramènent
les micros mais genre la dernière
seconde et ou même temps normal c'est un
fait c'est normal c'est un fils alors
bien ce gars a l'air vraiment vous avez
assuré solide elle donc là vous rentrez
sur scène et là c'est la délivrance
norway diouf
oui mais pas chaque phrase que je
prononçais un trottoir
je me rappelle pas et surtout elle était
millimétré elle résonnait d'abord avec
le la fonction publique dans ma tête je
sais c'est moche c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'effet tunnel moi des fois j'aimerais
réfugiés
je suis pas mieux face à la mc caw
logiquement été protégée alors qu'ils
hésiteront de loi
[Musique]
allez gaspé genre que maîtrise vais à
fond rien
[Musique]
on sait
toi
non
[Musique]
m
je
[Musique]
bye
ça
ambiance dj quantité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça choque ya besoin
merci à tous ces coups chanter il y en a
qui se ressemblent pas du tout - bahia
mua ouais il est pas con pas les règles
il ya un mec il est au téléphone avec
son mérite
c'est quoi digicode faire je n'ai jamais
solidaires
ça
[Musique]
or était à l'aise vraiment le moment
jouissif ça comme ça répond j'ai hâte
j'ai appelé la police
les gens bon bon bon bon léger brief
bail bail se termine les gens font ou
ont fait un jeu d'acteur un peu moyen
que vous allez voir en quelques secondes
regardez regardez bien et surtout
écoutez bien le freddy il ne connaît pas
être calme devant tant de jours vous
voyez macron quand tu dis c'est freddy
pendant cette nuit pour dire si je suis
libre je fais du catch wall street
attendait de meilleurs tu t'es dit
[ __ ] je panique ou là c'était du catch
je pensais qu'on allait se battre un
moment jusqu'à varié possible d'avoir
une compilation des moments clés
ensemble alignés
merci bien sûr tout est mon banquier en
ligne et de solidaires de ce mouvement
ouvrier d'imam
et la retrouve là et là il ya un truc
deux mois je m'entends pas mais les
retours thème était très très bas du
coup je crie là je chante et je crie je
reviens moi tu fais ça tout le temps
c'est pas un mec
[Musique]
le club med a généré grâce à un
métronome
ah oui j'ai donné mon téléphone je
dessinais un téléphone et la master
class les gags master class de lucas en
approche ah ouais ouais
regardez le master class de l'uqac
arrive on vient de chanter on est tous
s'essouffler lucas nous sort un discours
de fin sans bug de a à z c'est vrai coup
de moins bien je me souviens de la
livrée de série continue c'est déjà là
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
merci à toi vous voulez savoir le comble
j'en fasse moi vous avez dit j'étais
chaud pour faire une tournée que l'était
l'été des clubs des fois tu pas pêché ça
j'étais bouillon nos emblèmes et un oeil
à ce qu'il ya à retenir c'est que
globalement autour des mecs pas chanteur
bon déjà on a vécu un truc inoubliables
chez que je passe un moment fou c'était
assez incroyable qu'on parle d'un délire
de vidéos youtube et qu'on finit sur la
scène des solidays et surtout qui es tu
bien jean les huit premiers rangs de
gens qui regardent ça c'est fini
là dessus pas c'était là solidaires fin
non la fureur du web mais c'est pas
pareil vous la fait pas vraiment une
soirée halloween mais on n'a jamais
refait devant autant de gens dont autant
qu'ils étaient là vraiment juste pauvres
membres y avait vraiment moi j'étais
étonné de ça dans ma grosse angoisse
était de me dire tu as à un festival il
ya trop de gens ils sont là pour garder
les groupes jugés mal fini et qui
veulent vinh après la rochelle avant
qu'est ce qu'on fait là tu es en fait
non les gens étaient trop mignon trop
accueillant et tout donc voila merci à
vous c'était une aventure extraordinaire
et je pense qu'on a fait le tour de tous
ceux de l'été alors la question qu'elle
vient les amis 116-107 sancerre ces
questions que déjà c'est est ce qu'il y
aura une suite au jeu des vues quoi
c'est beaucoup de poids malheureusement
moi je suis pas pour que j'évoquais
j'avais écrit un texte
enfin je risque de faire tellement mieux
que ce que j'imaginais il y avait un
engouement tellement au delà de ce que
j'espérais et c'est qu'en fait je me dis
franchement on fera jamais mieux au
mieux dans le meilleur des cas on fera
aussi bien et j'aime pas ce truc
on va avoir une pression aussi en plus
du coup j'ai déjà changé
guests à me faire ch e loue parce qu'on
a quand même vécu un truc qui va mal
ajoutant on est liés par ce truc là
jamais tu vois des signes partout ce
coup là toute la suite aux sifflets la
suite qui nous a vraiment unique quoi
exactement le se sont étalés tourné les
clips aussi ça nous a grave approché par
il y avait trop de trucs c'était une
aventure humaine qui était fou j'étais
l'un des projets d'eau que j'ai fait
avec l'aventuré mais la plus intense et
riche derrière par un on est vraiment à
me tue à tous nous on fait plein de
trucs fin bref cessez le feu
et du coup la question que bien en plus
c'est bon c'est quand la fin de l'été
alors parce que c'était une complète qui
a gagné kevin jordan vit avec moi j'ai
besoin de temps ok je suis fier de vous
remettre non pas un trophée
[ __ ] certifié disque d'or on est parti
d'un tel réseau et vous avez un sens
incroyable
vous avez un [ __ ] tu dises que dans
merci merci à vous lasser fait trophée
hashtag émotions merci georges at c à
l'égard non parce que là c'est vraiment
la religion qui signe la fin de ses
profits ciellement la fin c'est de
laisser seul évidemment il y en a un
pour toi aussi quand même vu que tu fais
partie des gens nerfs là bas aussi ok
les gars vous avez pu disputer ouais
vous avez fait au total sur spotify 14
millions lui sur deezer vous avez fait
plusieurs millions et du coup il faut 15
millions de stream payant pour avoir
l'équivalent de 15 buts donc à savoir le
disque d'or travaillons la musique du
coup j'en ai déjà eu
j'ai eu des platines bon bref c'est sans
vouloir prêter pardon pardon faire
khezzar allait continuer génial non en
tout cas c'est le premier qui me fait
autant plaisir parce que c'est du coup
le mien dans ses meetings et du coup bah
merci le cas parce que sans toi merci à
vous c'est votre talent vous merci aux
gens qui ont écouté
merci ça c'est très bon et ensuite c'est
grâce à tous ceux qui ont partagé qu'on
filme et quand ça passait en bois qu'on
parlait des deux passages au solide et
est ce que tu vois qu'on partager autour
d'eux comme 11e bonne tu vois les
donations c'est des petites actions
individuelles genre de le fait de
partager on se disait qu'on n'a rien ils
le font déjà
sont déjà pleins d'abord regarder à quel
point ça change les choses je veux dire
regardez ils ont fait disque d'or pour
un son qui est un délire d'une vidéo
youtube quoi croyez en vos rêves j'ai
fait disque d'or alors que je n'ai rien
on croyait en vous c'est donc officiel
et matri games avait prédit crédit et
que les harengs plan est 10e duel de
faux hit de l'été et le rapport
tellement qu'ils font au lycée pour la
blague en tournée en fait c'est quoi si
ce projet là n'avaient pas été achetées
sur une chaîne d'un homme qui est
présent là lights ou cabas et parce
qu'il fait genre et qui n'avait pas fait
cette démarche n'avait pas tout prévu et
c'est vous c'est votre tard on aimerait
remercier s'il vous plaît luc alphand et
quesqui si c'est dans les dix qui sont
trop bas merd faut les mains du tout les
gars en l'air on fait tout refait penser
tout jamais la retour quelqu un le
numéro deux et mon coeur fait
même toi je penses quoi toi je te dis
pas
bye bye
by si tu fais des sages de type a et b
bye bye bye bye si tu fais du sein